[Music]
hi
look pretty nice
i'm so bad at this
but
hello can i please have sex with you i'm
sorry
may i have sex with you
i couldn't help but
notice you from
across the bar i don't know why i said
it like that there's nothing funny about
that it's just your uh your cleavage is
and that's what it's for you know let's
i mean you did that consciously so
that's a biological thing and i
have responded to that urge
not i mean not yet hey girl wanna go
back to my place and i'll show you the
action figure i made of you hey wait
where are you going
hey
do you um want to make millions
of babies with me probably too many too
many babies i only want like two to
three because
it hurts to have babies and i actually
was scared to we could adopt hey
hey you
in the blue shirt
no not you your shirt is green her
you and the blue shirt
please get out of the way please get out
of the way can you please get out of the
way your shirt is aquamarine at best
okay hey
do you think taylor swift's vagina
smells like fruit by the foot
didn't we used to have sex
hi
um look at us all alone
you know there's
there's no coming back from this
oh um
no
look i'm sorry you're really nice but
you know i i'm married i it's just not
going to work out i mean
even if i wasn't i
i'm sorry i should have said that look
why don't you uh climb up my leg and
have a ball
i only i only have one testicle so
that's why i said it uh it makes sense
if other guys say that to you then and
they have two testicles and
that's unfair
i only have one so that's why i would
say it's it's grammatically correct that
way what do you want to see
some sound effects
girls kind of like that but okay
here's a car door slamming
the girl with the blonde hair and the
blue shirt behind you here's a car door
opening
get in the car [ __ ] we can dance
we can dance here let's both put our
hands behind our back where we're going
we don't need arms
did i offer you a cranberry
[Music]